okay so my name is Abraham or abami and
I'm a PhD candidate at benan University
in Israel for data science I research
things that are related to computational
social science and natural language
processing and so on um today I'm going
to talk about um the internet's best
experiment yet which H show disclaimer
um it's not my title so the title was
given by Newsweek on April
2017 and it was given to the experiment
that we're going to talk about and the
experiment itself is part a major part
of my PhD disertation and we'll talk
about it in a few minutes um and I do
think that it's indeed the best
experiment that has been done on over
the over the web and I must say that
after 2017 the there were couple of
interesting things that happened
afterwards and we'll talk about it
towards the end of the of the lecture um
so I see that seven of you
um are not aware to Wall Street bet
community and the other ones are aware
um so let's talk for a minute about the
Wall Street bets so um Wall Street bets
is um a community or a subreddit on
Reddit and it was you know just a
regular community on Reddit dealing with
trading and financial stuff and so on
but on January 2021 they became really
famous and big shock to all over the
world after they did a short squeeze on
a specific stock on on GameStop GameStop
stock and the reason they did so is to
try and cause a lot of damage or a lot
of of loss of money to the big giants in
Wall Street and they did it quite
success successfully and since then they
became really famous and you know a lot
of people joined the the community and
so on but this is only an example of the
power of communities over the web so
online communities are
really interesting powerful and so on um
so on one hand online communities are
really complex they consist of many
users they have a lot of ways to
communicate you know pictures um videos
text gestures and so on and they
maintain they maintain complex relations
between the users themselves and also
between other communities and they have
also they also evolve over time they
might change within days and so on so
it's quite hard to analyze and
understand the Dynamics within a
community and between communities but on
the other hand they are really
fascinating because they are so powerful
as the example I showed there earlier
and they serve as a microcosmos of our
real life communication and again they
can fight they can coordinate engage and
so on they have really a lot of power
these days once you know online
communities become so big and huge and
Powerful um okay the second question I'm
going to send you is about our place and
um if you can just take a look at the
question itself the poll I'm ask asking
whether you know or not our place
um so I see that again approximately
half of you know and the other ones um
not um or maybe most of you don't know
which which is good because I I'll try
to give you some motivation about the
this specific experiment which was
really fascinating um before that um one
slide about Reddit so those who don't
know Reddit so Reddit is a um platform
social platform for people to discuss
topics um it's one of the most popular
websites website worldwide with millions
of users and it is built in a way that
communities can act can communicate and
so on so each Community has its own
ecosystem and you can contact with other
members on the community for example
there is a community for for football
and soccer and for pizza stuff and for a
Wall Street bed so each uh person or
group of people that want to discuss
some topic they can generate a new
community and this is the way Reddit is
built um of course each um Community or
subreddit has its own moderators and
they apply the rules and guide people
how to behave and act and talk and so on
and um so this is an example yeah I took
this week from R python which is the
community in Reddit for Python and there
was an announcement about our Global Pi
Pata Global our conference and people
again can share this uh this in this um
post they can comment you can see here
the comment so there are lot of
Engagement H ways to to talk with others
um okay Reddit our place so
on April 1st
2017 uh Reddit announced a new subreddit
which was published to the community to
the whole community and there was a
description on the subreddit which is as
follows there is an empty canvas you may
place a tile upon it but you must wait
to place another individually you can
create something but together you can
create something more and the most
important part is that
you must wait to place another so the
the point was as follows there was an
empty canvas of thousand by thousand
pixels and there were no rules no
guideline no one told you what to do the
only thing as a user that you could do
is to take a virtual color and place it
on the canvas and the catch was that
once you place a a color you are blocked
for 5 to 20 minutes meaning that you
cannot really control the whole canvas
but once you get other people that think
like you or you engage with other people
you can do something interesting H after
3 days the the experiment was ended by
the already developers um so this was
the after one hour of the experiment you
can see the canvas thousand by thousand
you can see a few colors here and there
you can see the Highlight uh areas in
the middle and also here here and also
here um and what happened a long time so
let's try if we can uh see
it I hope you can see my screen and this
is a fastforward video of what happened
on the canvas okay so you can see a lot
of colors a lot of flags here here and
there you can see the um the blue is
expanding towards the the center of the
canvas and you can see in the middle
white and black efforts trying to you
know expanding to other places here you
can see really interesting thing that
happened between Germany and France so
again back to history and Wars H so
Germany is concurring France in a second
France is going up and then the European
Union is coming to make peace and the so
it's here you can see the monaa here and
also here on on the top and and a lot of
you know
Wars um engagements between
communities um a lot of pictures and
really um historic event and hence it
was announced as the best experiment the
internet best experiment yet um so this
is the final picture of the of the
canvas which is quite amazing because if
I would have asked you what do you think
would happen on such a canvas when you
allow multiple users to do whatever they
want I guess most of you would say a
whole chaos or you know nonone non
interesting things or non-polite things
and so on but actually it was quite nice
and um um I I'm researching this
phenomena of our place through my PhD um
so two examples of things that happen on
the canvas one is the Osho Osho is a is
a game is is a computer game so the
community tried to place his its artwork
on the canvas and you can see here that
someone is trying to avoid them so this
is called the black void the black void
tried to you know erase a lot of
pictures and they became really a war
with alsoo another interesting area is
here you can see few Flags H so you can
see the New York Rangers which was
vanished throughout the experiment on
top of them came a flag and then the
flag also we raised so there are a lot
of wars and um between communities um
other things that we saw on the
experiment is that H there there there
is a lot of coordination so how do
people communicate and so on so here
it's a an example of dbat which appeared
on the canvas at the early time of of
the of the experiment but later on it
was vanished um so you can see that
actually really pixeling the the the the
pixels and asking people to to help them
H here you can see the Peppa frog um
asking people explicitly to mark their
color in a specific place here you can
see a coordination between countries so
this is the flag Alliance um and this is
this is a nice example yeah between
coordination between countries which did
something together you can see here the
heart and there are a lot of Hearts
between countries which came to a pie
treat treaty between them and could um
work together within the borders they
they
defined okay in terms of data and this
is the important part for this
conference um so what was released by
Reddit after after the experiment is the
um actual an actual ual annotations of
people of the tiles throughout the
experiment so you could see the color
the time stamp H and the and the place
where the pixel was was allocated a
second uh data source which we have used
is the Atlas project and the atlas
project is probably the most important
resource that we have used in this um
effort this is the Atlas okay so the
atlas is an effort that was done by a
few redditors after the experiment ended
and they asked people from Reddit to
Mark the place where their Community act
acted so people could enter this website
and say you know in this place the
monian community H played and and
acted here India so the people from
India mark this place and say here we
acted and marked our our
flag so this is the second source that
we had
um in addition we had partial
information about the actual users that
participated in the experiment uh but we
didn't make use of this of this data at
all in our in our research um
additionally what we added to to our uh
data sources is the Comm commities that
participated in the in the experiment
which we call it s+ and a sample of
communities that did not participate in
the experiment so approximately in ready
there are millions of communities in
this specific experiment approximately
1,200
communities participated and
approximately 700 of the communities
could place their artwork on the canvas
at the final
stage um I'll skip this one this is a
bit of information about what what we
had in addition so so first experiment
that we did is to try and understand
which communities are going to
participate in the experiment this is
the first question that we asked the
second question was about the success
level of communities so let's take a
simple Community I don't know um India
as we saw earlier so we try to
understand what's the success level of
our India in terms of how many pixels
they placed on the canvas what's the
community size so for example if our
India is a huge community and they
placed a really little artwork on the
canvas their success is not that high on
the other hand if it's a tiny Community
which placed even 10 pixels their
success level is much higher so we took
U into consideration also the community
side the complexity that we calculated
is in terms of of the entropy of the
artwork so for example take the the
black void the black void was an effort
of few rors that try to erase pictures
so the only thing that they had to do is
to ask their participants to you know
Mark as much as possible red um black
pixels on the canvas it's not that
complicated on the other hand there were
communities that try to place really
complex pictures on the canvas like I
don't know dem monaa or you know complex
flags and so on so we also consider the
complexity of the artwork that was tried
to be H done by by the community and
also the location so the location means
the how popular was the area that the
drawing
was the community that acted on the
canvas whether it was very popular area
or not so all this data we have it per
community so this is the data that we
release and and I'll show in a second
the how data looks like H but generally
speaking so we have each row is a
community and we have the columns which
mean whether they survive or not how
many pixels they place what is the
complexity of the artwork that they try
to allocate how popular was the area
that they acted in and so on um here you
can see some correlation
between the community size and the
number of pixels um you can see that in
general yeah big communities could place
many pixels but you can also see for
example there is the community of
Germany H so they have quite a large
community size but on the other hand
they had maybe the
largest artwork on the canvas um on the
other hand the Donald which is a
community of uh Trump supporters they
are a huge Community but their artwork
is not is not that big um okay I'll show
a few results now the results here are
in terms of machine learning that we ran
so I know it's not the focus of the of
the conference so I'm going to do it
really quick I'm just going to give some
insights about the what we try to do in
the research effort so we try to
understand the find and analyze the
engagement the engagement level of
communities and also the success level
of communities how so how did we do it
we took the data from the experiment
which I showed earlier and we built
various predict prediction models to to
predict the engagement level the
engagement level and also the success
level of online communities afterwards
after we build the prediction models we
evaluated them and use explainability
tools to understand the factors behind
the success so for example if a
community success really well we try to
understand what's the reasons that they
had such a success this is the
methodology um here I'm showing a few
results you know this is the engagement
level so here in this uh results I'm
presenting how good we are able to
predict whether a community is going to
participate in the experiment or not and
you can see here there results I'm going
to skip a few slides because I think
it's not the most interesting part here
you can see also results in terms of
success level okay so we try to predict
the success level per Community whether
their success was high or low um and I
do want to talk in the last five minutes
that I have I do want to leave a few uh
minutes for questions about the
experiment H so between 2017 and 2022 a
lot of developers and redditors asked
Reddit to redo the experiment and they
did so and this was a much larger
experiment more than 10 million users
participated um they
had 160 Millions tile allocations I
recall on the first experiment there was
1.2 million pixels here it was much
bigger H it was announced a few days in
advance so the experiment was known to
to the users and this is very important
H because in the first experiment no one
knew about it no no one knew what to
expect here it was announced a few days
before and people can you know
could tell their their friends you know
come and and there is an experiment and
we must place our flag on on the convas
and so on and there were two expansions
of the canvas you will see it in a
second and there were a larger set of
colors compared to the first experiment
so here there were I don't know maybe 32
colors compared to 16 in the first one
and it lasted for three and a half days
and this is the first hours of the
experiment again Wars and so and
countries so you can see Ukraine which
was very popular on the first hours of
the experiment you can see Oso again
back from the 2017 experiment and I do
want to show you again a fast forward of
the experiment itself
um I'm not going to show the whole
experiment because it's it's a bit long
uh but you can see again Flags again the
black void in the middle
um let's skip a bit to the first
expansion of the canvas you can
see an extra place for for other
communities and existing communities
and a day later there is another
expansion of the canvas which goes
behind and um many more colors and
pictures and so on and once again this
experiment um the data of this
experiment was released meaning that we
had the annotations of the tiles
according to Time color and location and
in addition we also had the information
from the atlas so the as I showed
earlier the Atlas um of 2022 is here and
you can see a mapping of all artworks
and in the mapping we can understand
which Community played in which place
meaning that we can again map per each
Community their success level whether
they survive or not how popular was the
area that they acted in and so on and
that's the second effort that that we
did this is again the final
canvas at the end um so we use the atlas
as I said we calculated the same
measures as 2017 complexity popularity
of the area number of pixels and so on
um this this time it was much much
complex to calculate because there were
so many pictures and so many overlapping
pictures so it took us over a year only
to come up with the final you know CSV
of community and all the measures um we
do take into account the expansions of
the canvas meaning that a specific area
is not you know people cannot access
this specific area it was if it was in
the second expansion so we took this
fact into account while calculating for
example the popularity of the area so we
also take into account how long the
pixel was open for for the users to be
to to place um kn information about
users at all in this time and overall
there were approximately 2,500
communities actively participated in the
experiment again back to 2017 there were
approximately half of the communities
that
participated
um yeah I maybe I'll have one one sec
one minute so I'll show um how it looks
like the data sets so here you can see
this is how the data set looks like okay
so we have the community name the size
of the community in terms of number of
participants and whether they
participated in the experiment this 2017
whether they participated or not a
second data set that we release is the
success level meaning each row is a
community we have the total number of
pixels the total diameter which is also
a measure that we calculated the entropy
the demand in the area that they
anticipated in and also whether they
survived or not and in 2022 we have the
same format as 2017 again each row is
community we have the number the area
that they they they haded the final uh
canvas how many users they have the
entropy and so on and this is where we
release this data for you know
researchers and other people to to take
a look at and use for research or any
other thing that you think it's relevant
um I'll stop here if you have questions
if not I I'll I'll jump to the summary
[Music]
um other any
or okay so so I'll continue um to the
summary um so I I research online
communities the Our Place experiment is
um we call it a natural experiment for
to research and to build predictive
models to by using the data so the the
whole point is the data that was
released by Reddit and afterwards by
Reddit users which is the Atlas allowed
us to do a real deep research about the
behaviors of communities in an online
engagement
experiment um I presented the rplace
data and the model that we that we built
um the 2022 experiment we didn't model
at all we only Built the data set itself
and it has been pre-processed but yet to
be explored so we will release it and
for those who wish to try to use it
maybe predict the success level maybe
see if there is any correlation between
2017 and 2022 experiment these are all
um future work that we plan to do you
can see it here one last thing is that
this year actually few months ago so
there was another rplace experiment that
took part again in Reddit it lasted for
six days and there were
approximately 8 and a half million users
participating um actually it happened
after um you
know a lot of redditors were not happy
let's put it this way um with what is
going on in Reddit because the Reddit
owners decided not to allow third third
party apps to access the website and
there was
um a big war against the Reddit holders
so Reddit decided okay our place was an
amazing experiment let's do it again and
that's what happened um I haven't looked
yet at what what has been in
2023 but again comparing to 2022
experiment um it was less attractive H
there were less pixels placed and you
know it lasted for longer and there was
a big criticism about why did they do
this experiment specifically after uh
after what happened on Reddit but it's
still it's still very interesting to to
take a look and compare it to 2022 and
2017 um that's it um I'm also sharing
the GitHub of my lab you can contact me
with any question um I'll be happy to
answer your question afterwards or now
whatever and thank you very much for
listening
and I'll take the the one question that
that was here so can you share one of
the favorite facts that you discovered
in your research H so yeah I'll I'll
I'll share one of them which I I think
is quite surprising um so one of the
things that we saw is that H we we
tested whether moderated communities
success more in the experiment and we
were sure that you know plural
communities that people can say whatever
they want and they are open to anything
would would have much success level but
we found out the the opposite we found
that communities that are quite
restrictive
with quite tough moderation are more
likely to success and you know we can
excuse that by you know if you are
telling your people what to do exactly
where and when it's much easier for the
community to to act in such a um you
know
um really stressful situation where you
have to fight for your place in the
canvas um we also found out of course
that engaged communities with uh when
they response to others so people know
each other by name for example give us a
higher probability to success in the in
the experiment